[Music]
that is to say that he was a player here from a
very young age, his dad was a
technical director so in the end he is
not an average player, he is a player who
today and perhaps  the best
current French player but to have this
chance to play in a club where
the best
French player was trained, it's sure that it's
a pleasure for the feet, it's a
dream, it's  a perfect example and my
favorite type is Mbappe I take
the example
by dribbling and having fun
on the pitch
I am inspired by him it's my
favorite type I assert myself as sexy in his
positions his speed  and Cédric and thanks to
him I can have fun on the field
[Music]
and this evening of motivated Family
[Applause]